[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este 11 de abril se cumple el 20
aniversario del golpe de estado que
sufrió hugo chávez en la crónica de
historia de esta semana repasamos el que
quizá fue el momento más crítico del
expresidente venezolano durante su
tiempo en el poder un acontecimiento que
estuvo a punto de terminar con su
gobierno y que sin duda marcó el
transcurso futuro de sus decisiones
políticas y su relación con la oposición
para el año 2002 hugo chávez todavía
estaba en la primera legislatura y
apenas llevaba tres años en el cargo
este militar había ganado
democráticamente las elecciones de 1998
después de haber protagonizado un
fallido golpe de estado en 1992 su
victoria supuso una ruptura del
establecimiento político que gobernaba
en venezuela desde hacía años y se
produjo gracias a una serie de promesas
de cambio que sobre todo interpelaban a
la clase social más desfavorecida en
venezuela y al hartazgo de muchos
sectores con la clase política del
momento durante sus primeros años y
gracias a la mayoría lograda en las
urnas el gobierno chavista consiguió en
1999 la constitución venezolana e
intentó comandar una serie de reformas
estructurales que desde un comienzo
chocaron con las cúpulas empresariales
de esta nación algunos de los cambios
más controversiales giraban en torno a
la petrolera estatal pedevesa eje
fundamental de la economía venezolana
chávez tuvo varios desencuentros con los
dirigentes de esta compañía con la
patronal de empresarios fedecámarás y
con algunos altos mandos militares es
así como se llega al 11 de abril la
persistencia de la crisis económica y
social que atravesaba venezuela hizo que
varias organizaciones opositoras
empresariales y sindicales convocaron
una huelga general que terminó en
disturbios frente al palacio
presidencial de miraflores entre
opositores oficialistas y fuerzas de
seguridad un caos que acabó con la vida
de 19 personas e hirió a decenas más que
causó un shock en venezuela y que
derivaría en el posterior golpe de
estado la autoría de estos asesinatos
siempre fue motivo de polémica entre el
oficialismo y la oposición
pero el 12 de abril el general lucas
rincón fue el encargado de anunciar la
supuesta renuncia de hugo chávez tras la
petición del ejército un hecho que el
chavismo siempre negó pero que sirvió de
pretexto para declarar el vacío de poder
y el nombramiento como mandatario
interino de pedro carmona presidente de
la patronal de empresarios fedecámarás
para ese momento un movimiento que causó
mucha polémica pero que fue apoyado por
un sector del ejército y gran parte de
la oposición
carmona juramento como presidente el
mismo 12 de abril y acto seguido revocó
las controversiales 49 leyes de chávez
rechazó la constitución bolivariana de
1999 y disolvió todos los organismos
públicos a la espera de elecciones
pedro carmona estanga en mi condición de
presidente de la república de venezuela
juro ante dios todopoderoso
ante la patria y ante todos los
venezolanos
reestablecer la efectiva vigencia de la
constitución de la república de
venezuela de 1999 chávez fue detenido
por tropas golpistas y encarcelado en un
cuartel militar en caracas en primera
instancia para después ser llevado a una
prisión militar desde su lugar de
reclusión fue donde escribió una carta
donde rechazaba que hubiera dimitido
algo que hizo que una parte del ejército
encabezada por el general raúl isaías
baduel intentara rescatarlo para
devolverlo a su cargo a nivel
internacional la reacción fue diversa
gobiernos como el de argentina o cuba se
opusieron a reconocer al gobierno
interino diferente fue la respuesta de
ejecutivos como los de españa el
salvador o eeuu de hecho el papel que
tuvo la administración de george bush
fue siempre una de las cuestiones más
controversiales ya que el chavismo lo
acusó directamente de instigar el golpe
de estado aunque nunca se pudo comprobar
así reaccionó la casablanca después de
conocer lo sucedido en venezuela los
dichos los detalles aún no están claros
sabemos que la acción alentada por el
gobierno de chávez provocó esta crisis
de acuerdo con la mejor información el
gobierno de chávez reprimió
manifestaciones pacíficas pero sin un
apoyo total ni internamente por parte
del ejército ni en el exterior el golpe
fracasó el 13 de abril
hugo chávez fue liberado y recibido con
entusiasmo por sus seguidores incluso
esta fecha sirvió para forjar uno de los
lemas chavistas más reconocidos todo 11
tiene su 13 en su vuelta al poder fueron
claves las fuerzas armadas que se
mantuvieron fieles a su gobierno y las
acciones de sus votantes en la calle que
salieron a protestar contra el ejecutivo
provisional de la oposición
[Aplausos]
el golpe de estado de 2002 marcó un
punto de no retorno en la relación de
hugo chávez con los sectores contrarios
al chavismo dentro de venezuela y con
algunos países occidentales como eeuu la
desconfianza se adueñó del chavismo que
fue aumentando sus cuotas de poder en
todas las instituciones del estado
implementando sus políticas fidelizando
al ejército con el nombramiento de
oficiales leales y a la vez aislándose
de una parte considerable de la
comunidad internacional acciones que se
acentuaron con la llegada de nicolás
maduro al poder y que desembocaron en la
situación actual de venezuela con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]